Speaking of robots,
Tiger Woods used to be the most
dominant force in golf.
[ Laughter ]
He used to be the most
dominant force in golf,
and maybe the best ever
to play the game.
Now he stinks,
which has left a giant void
in the sport.
It's been awful.
And I wanted to find out
how people were dealing
with his demise,
so I went to the place
you always go to
when you want to talk
about golf --
Crenshaw Boulevard
in South Central L.A.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What are you doing now to fill
your void in the golf world?
A whole lot of nothing.
Can you name five golfers
ranked ahead of Tiger Woods?
No.
Can you name one?
Who's your second favorite
black golfer?
[ Laughter ]
How you been filling
your golfing void
since Tiger's fallen off?
The only golfer I know about
is Tiger Woods.
That's the only --
Well,
there's Charles Barkley.
[ Laughter ]
Man.
Are you, uh,
a big golf fan at all?
Not really,
but I watch Tiger a little bit.
But nah,
I don't really like that.
He's the 258th ranked
golfer now.
[Bleep] that's great.
No, that's not good.
Why?
He used to be
the top golfer in the world.
[Bleep] He getting old.
What you expect?
He didn't get 258th old,
though.
Baby, listen.
The new generation coming up.
Everybody get a turn.
He had his turn.
It's somebody else turn.
That's how life goes.
But he could have
a resurgence in his career.
He ain't gonna have [bleep]
It's somebody else turn
to [bleep] all the broads
and get all the hits,
you know what I'm saying?
If you got caught
cheating on your wife,
you think that would affect
your performance at the job?
First, she'd have to prove
it was me.
And I mean prove it's me.
Yeah.
Would you [bleep] Tiger?
Hell, no.
Not even with a [bleep] coat on.
Not even if he was,
like, real chill,
and, like, took you
on a nice date?
The hell
with Tiger Woods.
No, no, no.
Like -- like not even --
No.
If Tiger was like...
..."Hey, you want to go
see the...
No. No.
...Amy Winehouse
documentary?
No. No.
...And then...
No.
...get some sushi?"
I don't eat sushi.
No.
[Bleep] Tiger. No.
"With a coat on,"
what did that mean?
No.
What do you think
they should do
to make golfing more popular
in the black community?
I have no idea.
You think they should do
trash talking in golf?
They want you to be quiet
at the golf.
I know. That's why
we should change that.
Oh.
If you were a golfer
and you were trash talking,
what would you say
to another golfer?
"I [bleep] your father."
[ Chuckles ]
I would say stuff like,
"Life is finite.
We're playing a dumb game."
I would say stuff like that.
I might as well be drunk.
[Bleep]
"Life is meaningless.
Go ahead and putt."
Life is not meaningless.
It has a --
got a lot of purposes.
What's the purpose?
Make money...
No.
...and create
smaller versions of yourself?
I don't want to bring
any kids into this world, man.
Now, what if your father
had thought like that?
You wouldn't be here.
That was a different
thing then -- back then.
No, it wasn't different.
They didn't even
have condoms back them.
Yes, they did.
In '83?
They weren't popular,
though.
Well,
they're something like
things you hear about
but never see.
Yeah?
Just like the serial number
on a condom.
You ever seen that?
The serial number
on a condom?
Yeah.
Nah, I don't believe it.
Oh, well, you probably
don't have to roll it down
that far, so...
[ Laughs ]
Why'd you just call
my penis small?
Who do you think
is the next big black golfer?
♪♪
[ Scoffs ]
There's that one dude,
right?
I don't know if he's, like,
just full-on black.
He may be, like, French
or, like, Jamaican
or something, you know?
Even though that's, you know,
of the, you know, descent -- Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Mary Poppins
got hit by a car.
That ain't cool.
Who's the second best
black golfer?
I don't know.
I don't play no damn golf.
Hell, President Obama.
[Bleep]
Charles Barkley?
The hell with Charles Barkley.
Obama.
[ Camera shutter clicking ]
Tiger Woods, Obama,
Barkley.
Nah, Obama, Barkley,
then Tiger Woods.
Obama, Barkley,
Yeah. Yeah.
The holy trinity of golf.
Yeah.
Black golf.
Yeah, black golf.
[ Cheers and applause ]